So from here we want to have some sort of
indicator to say if I have a potion
So let's create a new variable and we're
going to say has health potion up here
And we're going to set SteveAnd we're going
to set its default value to false.
And while we're up here we can go ahead and
say like hero nameEquals the code Works
crusader.
And we'll set the villain name as well
And this is going to be the coding virusAnd
at this point you might be able to recognize
it.
What we did earlier with creating objects we
could probably do the same thing here
So I'm actually going to create a cons
hereI'm going to call this the hero. And
this is going to equal this object.
I'm going to have nameEqual the code Works
crusader.
And I need to make sure I have this comma
hereWill do health is 100. And has health
potion.
Is going to be falseI'm going to just. We'll
say.
And we'll just say it's the refactored
version of above and then let's do the same
thing here with this villain
You can just say const villain
And we'll say the name and then we'll give
the health of 150 as well
Perfect so right now we should have some
errors
Well actually not excuse me because we still
have these variables up hereBut from here I
can actually Target.
The hero.health
And I can actually just I'm going to use the
control D here I'm going to Target all my
villains health
Let's make sure that's all of themSee that's
going to be a problem there though.
This should be fine for now we'll say
villain DOT health
But I got to sneak in here I won't change
any of this but I do want it to equal my
villain to health here
Sweet awesome and I'm going to do the exact
same thing with my hero health
So it's fine my hero Health hereAnd then
we'll just Target all these hero health and
we'll say hero.health.
And then we'll change it here as well
And one last spot down in our drink potion
We'll change it to this objectAwesome.
Just a little bit better refactoring cuz
Like come into tomorrow's project that you
might be more comfortable just
creating that object instead of just
creating a bunch of variables that
Doesn't really tie too much to the hero
besides the fact that it's got the hero in
front of the name let's just create that
into an object
And I'll put the refactor from above as well
But now I have this property on my hero
object that has health potion
So I want to be able to check if hero has
health potion
So if we actually there's a two ways we can
handle this we can either put this
exclamation point
And let's give ourselves an alertWe're just
going to return this cuz we wanted it to
hard stop here.
So we'll say sorry youDo not have. A health
potion.
Unless just make sure we rub insult to
injury and we'll say add in our little test
tube here
Sweet so let's save that and go to our web
application
And if I try to hit potion nowWe get this
alert that says sorry you don't have that
health potion.
And because we're returning it I also won't
get any help either
So now we need to add some sort of
functionality that can actually flip that
bull
Cuz right now no matter whatOr has health
potion is always going to remain false
because that's what it's set to but.
now we need to create some sort of function
that will flip this bull to true
Which will then allow me to actually
increase my Hero's Health by 25
And since all my main functionalities built
inside this attack
I'm going to need some sort ofRoll for
potion here. Because I'm going to make some.
So I'm going to design this to give you a
percentage of a chance every time you attack
to essentially drop a potion
So it's actually create another function
after these since we're going to be working
within this attack
I'm going to make it underneath my hero
attack just to keep him in order and I'm
going to say function
We're going to sayWe'll say roll.
For health potion hereIt's going to have a
little bit of a D&D aspect to it.
So we're going to create this variable role
for health
And we'll do the same as earlier we'll do
our math that floor
And we'll do a math.ranum and we'll multiply
this by 11
So we should have a number
Actually let's do something different on
this oneLet's multiply it by 10.
Cuz I don't want it to actually be zeroTo 10
I want this to be one through 10.
It's outside of this let's actually add this
one
So now this roll for health will always be a
number 1 through 10 because of that plus one
because the max number I can have is a 9
right now but because of
that I can add the one and then the lowest
number I can have will always be a one
because if it's a zero it's going to get
that plus one as well
So now we get to create our opportunity to
actually get this potionSo we'll say if roll
for health is.
Greater than7.
Seven let's actually go to our hero
Get that has health potion Bowl so right now
we're going right back up here to line 10
we're saying hit this line
And now I want you to make it equal true
And after you do that let's do an alert so
we knowAnd we'll say you found a health
potion.
And let's let's put that test tube in there
it I like the way it looksThat's a little
extra Flair.
So let's save thisAnd let's make sure we
actually add it to this attack function as
well.
Cuz if we don't add it to this we'll never
actually be able to see it pop up
So at this point I should have a30% chance
to find a potion sweet.
And what's that a little strategyMake sure
I'm at least below 100.
To actually now get that random luck chance
so it's still just a game of luck
But this point it adds a little more Flair
to itOh man I'm getting really lucky here
but.
I'm trying to think really quick if anything
But this refactoring and putting them in
those private functionsMakes it so at any
point now.
We can change one thing in that functionSo
if I feel like okay maybe this is too easy
now.
Let's create this it needs to be higher than
eight or maybe that you only have a 1% orAn
actual 10% it has to equal 10.
So it's going to make it really hard so you
have a 10% chance
You can do different things just to increase
orIncrease the difficulty.
So now let's just add some quick
functionality to my health potion
We'll say if the hero will make sure weSet
it to 100 but we'll also just return.
And we'll keep this test tube thing going
we'll get the test tube in thereOr our
secret concoction.
And say you cannot drink a potionIf your
health is full.
Awesome let's do one more check as wellCuz
we don't want any any healing going on if.
You are your hero the code Works Crusader
hasIt's no longer with us.
I just realized this this is never going to
hit this alert we'll go back to itSo.
If we're at 0 or less than 0 Let's return
this alert here
And we'll just say you can't drinkIf you're
dead.
Let's actually add some crossbones here
yeahSpice it up a little bit.
And I noticed just thinking about after this
wasWrote in is.
This isn't going to work properly in the way
I want it toCuz it's going to. Put it back
to 100.
But then it's going to also
YeahSo this isn't going to work the way I
wanted to work right now.
Cuz right now I do want this to reset it
back to 100 century when I drink a potion
and it's going to over
go over the hundred I want to actually set
to 100 but I want this to return if my
health is above 100
So because it's always going to be at 100 at
this point this will actually never get
returned because it's never going to be over
or
Let me actually said that's not women
I just want to make two functions I'm at the
two
So right now I have it so
If his health goes over a hundred set it
back to 100 and then it's going to hit this
if your potion is you can't drink potion
if you're full I don't necessarily want that
to trigger every single time I just over
heal myself essentially so let's make an
else if here
And then we'll actually put if the hero
healthIs greater than 100 as well.
I kind of want to make these quick checks in
hereSo it's actually return this alert here.
So if I don't have a health potion I
shouldn't even be able to drink at all
But if I do have a health potion and my
health is well actually do both if
Move this guy here so we're pretty much
saying if all this happens
All the bad things that can happen now let's
go ahead and returnHero.health.
Plus equals 25
So I got to return there so we'll get it
else so say else
We can get rid of thisAnd at this point we
can actually do.
A ternary
And let's actually just create so a ternary
is going to be like an if statement so let's
get rid of here
Get rid of that and what's create ternary
based off this if statementSo the first part
of the ternary.
Is going to be essentially this conditionSo
I'm going to say if hero.health.
Is greater than 100And this is going to look
weird the first few times you try.
InThis is going to look weird the first few
times you actually make a ternary cuz we're
going to have this question mark.
And then this if this is true if my hero
health is above 100 let's go ahead and make
hero Health equal
100But if it's fall so if it is.
Nothing changes we could do
We do know empty string
Hold on hold on Zach I'm looking at Best
Practices
JavaScript I don't care about JavaNot right
now at least sir. 2021.
I don't know that the guy not even make a
ternary
With the hit
OkayI'll be back I'm going to stop recording
and make sure it's working.